Now for the answer.
At this point, n is equal to three, so we need to split the the input--
that is, the select tag--into three subsets.
We now have eight characters in here,
so the first subset has either two or three characters.
This is not the right answer,
because we now need to remove these subsets.
This is the entire set. There's nothing removed in here.
Over here there is not a 3rd removed but an entire half, namely the second half.
Therefore, this is wrong as well.
Over here, however, we have the first 3rd removed.
That is, the less than sign and the s have been removed.
This could possibly be a next test for delta debugging.
Other alternatives could also be the less than sign, the s, and the e,
which have been removed, but this option is not in here.
The last option is just testing the last third of the input,
and this means that not only 1/3 but 2/3 are removed,
and this is also not in the description of the algorithm.
This is the next test that delta debugging conducts.